yes
john good morning to you good morning to
everyone at home in fact you can hear
they're testing the sound system right
now just moments ago we saw bomb dogs
coming in and doing the sweep of the
area just to make sure that everything
remains safe for all of the visitors who
are going to be here today a couple
hundred people at least are expected i'm
going to step out of the way just so you
can take a look at the stage that
they've set up to honor the lives that
were lost on one october clark county
metro police co-hosting the ceremony
governor steve sisilak sheriff joe
lombardo they'll be among those on hand
the southern nevada multi-agency honor
guard will also be there and and this is
something really exciting to present
today some live music including a name
that you might be familiar with matt
skye he was a voice contestant and he's
going to be performing a song to honor
and remember those lost and the
sacrifices made that day
[Music]
[Music]
and sky i'll be performing that song
four years after as part of this
morning's ceremony it was written by
mark johnson who said that he wrote it
watching a colleague who was shot
recover slowly he says he hopes the song
will help more survivors moving forward
so this sunrise ceremony begins at seven
this morning the public is welcome to
come out and if you'd like to watch it
live you can do so on our website we'll
also be streaming it on our facebook
page as well another very emotional
ceremony happening this evening this one
at the healing garden downtown and
that's where we find our victoria saha
with a preview of that